[Music]
three constantly hi slackers a dead-end
telemarketing job and a whole lot of
horrible people workaholics is one of
the best shows about a group of dudes
doing a lot of nothing
now that Blake Adam and ders have said
goodbye to Rancho Cucamonga it's time to
take a look back at everything that made
workaholics possible come together a
couple of the workaholics creators have
been making each other laugh since they
were little kids Kyle knew it check the
guy who plays drug dealer Karl on the
show and Blake Anderson grew up together
in Northern California their first
collaboration was an elementary school
era comic called Funyun protectors about
anthropomorphic Funyuns snack rings who
were also superheroes they started
performing together in high school and
after graduation moved to Orange County
to attend Community College which is
where they met Adam Devine at an improv
class
Ponder's home joined the group when he
met Devine at second city in Los Angeles
the next step making web videos may
allure der comedy back in 2006 they
launched their mail order comedy sketch
group which was fairly successful even
before they landed on TV they had a
bunch of comedy shows did tours and were
basically going places among their
creative YouTube ventures and their own
website they created two myspace
exclusive comedy shows remember MySpace
if you do you're probably old
[Music]
I know we've never met before but we
should meet because we look close to one
another this is a scam once upon a time
it was the Facebook of its day so it
hosted a lot of exclusive media
including music comics and even web
series like the ones the workaholics
guys did
special delivery was a prank show
because every comic has to get the prank
stuff out of their system at one point
or another crossbows and mustaches was
an action comedy show that combined two
of the finest things ever created by
mankind of course myspace couldn't last
forever so the mail-order comedy team
went on to make bigger and better things
experimenting with the ideas that would
eventually become workaholics the flop
house while taping the first season of
workaholics Adam and Blake were
convinced that the show was gonna be a
flop to save money for the rainy days
ahead they actually lived in the
disgusting party house where the show
was taped while onder's lived in a real
home with his girlfriend Devine and
Anderson moved out when the show success
enabled them to afford proper shelter
but Anderson says the old place has
become a flophouse where their friends
and family have crashed Anderson's
younger brother lived there for a while
as did Divine's best friend from high
school
nevertheless Devine says the place
remains infested with giant newborn
sized rats
there wasn't one like 24-hour period
that we killed something like 18 rats
yeah we call it the night of many many
kills it's always sunny at Rancho a show
about a budget terrible people doing
horrible things
of course workaholics is called and It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia ripoff
which is basically a Seinfeld ripoff
anyhow workaholics has been called that
since before it even air and that was by
the creators even better they said it
straight to the cast of Sonny according
to a movie web interview with Blake
before the show even aired the cast of
workaholics drunkenly rushed up to the
cast of Sonny at a comic-con party to
tell them that their upcoming show was
basically a ripoff for what it's worth
the Sonny crew reacted positively and if
there was ever any doubt
Sonny's Glenn Howerton cast it aside on
Twitter straight out of Mordor
the season 1 episode muscled I'd like
the Flex begins with the stylish Lea
shot rap video sequence in which the
guys perform a song about being wizards
while dressed in long robes beards and
floppy hats don't make this wizard mad
don't make this wizard piss
I could kill a hill giant with the flick
of my wrist in the plot of the show
they're rehearsing for a performance at
a Renaissance Faire but the wizard rap
stick isn't new under the name the
Wizards they recorded and released a
full album of wizard rap called purple
magic in 2009 in fact they wanted to
pitch a show to Comedy Central about
gangsta Wizards before a network
executive told them to go with their
other idea a show without slackers
instead pong gone wrong in 2011 Blake
Anderson lived out a real-life event
that sounds like it could have happened
on an episode of workaholics and a wild
house party in Los Angeles he raised the
stakes in a game of beer pong by
attempting to dunk a ping pong ball by
jumping off a roof the whole thing was
captured on video and ghoulishly sold to
TMZ the accident resulted in a pretty
serious vine fracture well he broke his
back for those of you that dr. octagon
spine now I do
Anderson underwent back surgery but made
a full recovery and didn't miss a single
episode of playing a character who would
have done the same thing
Arrested Development one of the most
surprising cameos on workaholics came
courtesy of Mitch Hurwitz TV writer and
creator of Arrested Development after
the first season of workaholics aired he
contacted the troupe and told them they
were doing great work and that he'd like
to be a part of it in any way they
offered her what's the opportunity to
write an episode but he wanted a chance
to act so they wrote the part of cool
Eric the Human Resources guy for him I
love people to say that another way I
love people that one's got a little more
fun to it Hurwitz later repaid the favor
by casting the three main stars of
workaholics and cameo roles as airline
employees in the 2013 revival of
Arrested Development the end despite the
fact that Comedy Central probably would
have let the series live forever
Anderson home Devine a new a check all
decided that the 7th season of
workaholics would be the last in a
statement the crew thanked Comedy
Central its executives and the show's
fans quote for turning us from boys to
men it was an incredible run but we've
decided to leave on a high
a note get it in quote while the show
has ended the team's collaborative
efforts have not they're working on an
action comedy film called game over man
for Netflix and the conclusion of their
show will leave them more time to focus
on bigger projects written by Anders
Holm the movie has been described as an
action comedy akin to die hard in a
hotel which honestly sounds pretty fresh
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]